hello everyone and welcome back to the
2020 Tata Steel masters edition it's
round 11 and fallujah I had some very
strong opponents in the previous two
rounds well he had very strong opponents
in all the rounds but in the previous
two round she faced Magnus Carlsen and
Fabiano Khurana so the world champion
and water championship Challenger from
2018 and now he faces another former
world champion Vishwanathan Anand so
that's that some streak imagine playing
those three in a row now that being said
let's check out how he fared against
against Vichy so uh Felucia opens with
d4 now we had Knight f6 see for now east
six Knight to c3 and Anand goes for the
nimzo-indian defense we have Bishop to
b4 we have f3 the kamov variation of the
names of Indian and now d5 by Anand with
a3 pushing the bishop back or asking
maybe maybe we would like to capture so
Bishop goes back to e7
even though characters is is the the
most played line so on under goes back
Bishop e7 and now efore with D captures
on e 4f captures on e4 and c5 by Anand
and here it's a fairly standard line d5
is the is the main move here which makes
sense you want to grab space in the
center but oh it has a place he 5 and
it's a move that has been played only
once by Peter Lake oh yeah so sorry not
that Peter let go by if again in higher
against Peter like oh so an interesting
idea and well maybe maybe on and the is
not familiar with it since it was only
played once so far we have night f2 d7
and D captors on c5 we have nightcap
force on e5 by Anand and now an early
Queen trade Queen captures Bishop
capture send Bishop to e2 and here
Knight B to d7 is what Peter like Oh
played in the 2019 grants with Fida
grants with that game ended in a draw
against having any naira but here we
have Bishop to d7 by Anand and it is as
a move 11 that we have a completely new
game so all it has a continuous to
develop the knight of three we have
Knight captures an f3 Bishop captures an
f3 now puts pressure on b7 and Anand
blocks with Bishop to c6
now a Larissa does have a cc pond here
but he's hoping to get b4 in b5 in and
it should be should be a plus for him
we have Knight to e4 now blocking
getting the knife to a much nicer Square
Knight to d6 check also also is an idea
Bishop to c7 in the now b4 as planned
now we have Knight to d7 by Anand now
saying that okay if you go with b5
connecting just captures captures and
Knight captures and c5 attacks the
bishop also guards the b7 pawn so after
Knight to d7 with Bishop Bishop to b2
putting pressure on the g7 point and now
on unblocks with Knight to e5 I'll also
put pressure on c4 nd you can capture
the bishop it will however you will
expose your g7 point if you do that here
all it has a castles Queen side and
island captures the bishop with the
sharpie actress nf3
G captures and now Bishop f4 with check
and this is a very useful trick for many
reasons but the most important one being
after King to b1 + f6 not allowing this
captures now we have rook H to g1 by Ali
Rezai going after g7 and here Anand can
now play King to f7 and now due to the
bishop therefore check and the King
being moved to be won now you cannot
push b5 because here after a bishop
characters on e4 it comes with check if
this didn't come with check if the king
was still on c1 then white would have
this very nice in-between rook to d7
check and then after rook captures on g7
you you basically resign here but now
with this being a check now you would
have the capture and then rook a d8 it
does not allow this very nice rook lift
for Alireza
so here after king to f7 ali reza goes
Knight to d6 with check with Bishop
captures and now unfortunately you
cannot play C captures and unpin because
you lose the f3 pawn and then you will
have some problems guarding against
these these four gentlemen here your
rook is under attack rook moves now look
H the d8 is coming and the black is just
excellent here plus you just grabbed a
very very important point so after
Bishop captures and e6 we have rook out
for Sun d6 and the
comes in g5 by Island and no longer you
have to worry about the g7 pawn and the
bishop nicely covers the d7 square the
f3 pawn is still under attack so you
have to play a bit of a passive Mook to
f1 to defend it and then out a six
preventing b5 of course we have teamed
to see two holidays I wants to bring the
King to e3 maybe even further in the
future
rook H to d8 now preparing a nice rook
trade we have King to d2 there's no way
to take advantage of this weird position
of the king so the king is just there on
his way to e3
and now II five making the way for the
king Islands plan is the capture here
allow this fixing of the pawn structure
but it will get the King to e6 which is
very important from e6 you will guard e5
point so you can maybe continue pushing
with f5 and so on so King III by Odessa
and now rook captures on d6 yes this
does fix your pawn structure but it also
allows the activation of the king we
have kink the e6 and now c5 so now this
is a very interesting position black is
better but why is black better that's
the question so what would you play here
it feel free to pause the video for a
minute or maybe even two and you know
you know I soak in the position what
would you play here well I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who are able to do it
congratulations for being an excellent
well finder of plants in an end game and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show
viable options are either a5 you wanna
bust break open this pawn chain rook to
G it is an idea followed by g4 or even
maybe maybe a nice rook maneuver all the
way to h3 but b6 is best this is one
place and it well it will either if you
allow captures captures to get a nice
open B file for the black rook or if you
don't well you just constantly have to
worry about it so here ali reza played
age four he wants to try and get a get
an open file for his rook on the
kingside island plays h6
we have h captures h captures and now
see capture some v6 like I said if you
if you don't want to capture this you
want if you want play something like
rugby one put a rug behind the passport
then Anand will capture and play rook to
b8 and then now with the Rope coming to
b3
it's just a very strong position for
blacks so here instead ali reza decides
for c captures here and now
rook the BA to going after the pawns
here you could you could also capture on
d6 however then you allow rook to d1
check and then white gets a nice look on
his open file and in the future also the
b6 pawn might might become an issue
so instead after C captures and b6 we
have looked to be 8 by Anand and now
rook to d1 putting rug behind a passed
pawn also defending it but Anand is not
worried it seems like it was more
natural to capture this pawn here but
Anand has a different plan and he knows
since the White has a dark square bishop
that he's never crossing this light
square it doesn't matter what what it is
it does here so we know if it appears to
be a very strong passed pawn you are
never crossing the white square here and
also ali reza is three minutes on the
clock so by not capturing you're
actually forcing him to burn more time
and it's only move 32 so ali reza still
needs to make 8 more moves to reach time
control whereas Anand has some 26
minutes so rook captures and b6 first
King f2 we have Bishop to a for taking
some very important squares from the
from the white rook and now this is on
hands points now if you go rook c1 to
grab hold of the open C file then you
lose this pawn and then it's well you
you are down upon and the the win this
pawn mass starts marching forward it
will be very hard to defend
so here rook the DT was played by ali
reza and now comes Luke the b8 now on
and we'll try to shifted the rook Kurt
to the other side of the board and it's
hard to make a move for ali reza you
cannot move the rook from the defense of
this pawn here the bishop really doesn't
have it doesn't have a good good thing
to do and you can just play a move with
the king so it's what Ali Reza does King
g3 will group the c8 now by Anand and
now King back to F 2 still all arrays
are without a viable plan we have looked
the c4
and probably with the idea of either
eater trying a 5 or or maybe going just
all the way to the kingside with rook to
h4 what King to g3 by Alireza and now
rook back to look back to see 8 by Anand
he's now deciding that shifting the rook
over via the Kings side is better
King f2 we have worked a trade and now
came to g3 we have worked the h1 you
cannot prevent rook h3 or or h1 both at
the same time so King G - and now rook
the b1 putting pressure on the bishop
King g3 the just repeating moves and now
Bishop the c6 now Anand wants to play
rook f1 and put pressure on the f3 pawn
here King F to not allowing this but now
King d7 again asking Reza what's your
move if you move the rook then I capture
the pawn here if you move the bishop
anywhere I get rugby 3 in and then well
you're a three pawn is gone
so King g3 is played in the now look to
f1 going after the pawn and now rook d3
I forgot to mention this already move 44
so the time control has been reached to
authorize again more time here he does
have a lot of time he can use to
calculate so here there is a this.e 4
movie for is a very forcing line point
being that after captures and captures
the rook is under attack rook to be -
now you start pushing your pawns here
and it's again very hard to find the
move there should be 5 if you want to
activate your rook so so the pawn is
defended but now rook f3 trick King to
h2 or some somewhere and now for example
rookie actress on 83 or if you don't
capture or if you don't play Bishop to
e5 you have to keep it here but then
your rook is paralyzed so now you you
there's no way to keep an eye on d6 pawn
and entity a3 pawn but again this is
something all it is I would perfectly
calculate so Anand doesn't want to give
him that undone place King to e6 and
just tells him you don't have a move
here and indeed all eraser does not have
a move here the engine stopped
recommendation here is rook to c3 just
wasting a move but attacking the bishop
but then Bishop d5 and the next move you
are going to pick up the d6 pawn and
then it's just a well
you take it from there so Allah Reza's
not ready to part with his spawn after
King to e6 egos King to g4 instead but
now Anand has rook to be one he attacks
the bishop if you move the bishop
like I said Roxy three then you get Ruby
three you go after the pawn so rook the
d2 defending and now rook the g1 with
checkpoint being you have to move away
from the defense of the pawn King to h3
is played and now what do you play here
do you capture the pawn or or do you not
capture the point let's say you capture
the pawn I'm just gonna tell you it's
it's a terrible move but you have to
figure out why it's a terrible move so
feel free to pause the game a video and
try to figure out why this doesn't work
well I'll give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on supporting
excellent tactics in an opposite colored
Bishop endgame and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show for those of
you who found the d7 that's not the
reason if you found these seven then g4
will be deadly because after g4 check
you have to move the King you can go up
the board because well g5 you do not
have g5 so you have to go back in h2 now
rook h1 share King g3 rook h3 check King
of two and now rook h2 check King III
and now rook captures and you guard the
queening square so the rook has to be
captured but now you pick up the pawn
and now you are four points to two
points of course completely winning for
blacks so after Bishop captures an f3
the reason why it doesn't work is
actually Bishop captures on e5 so
congratulations to all of you who found
that now the point is if the King
captures now you really do have d7 so
you have to capture with the pawn and
now d7 and now the same line only
results in a draw g4 check but now you
have access to h4 because there is no
point on f6 preventing the King from
reaching g5
so now rook h1 check King g5 and now
there is nothing better than to give up
the rook so everyone's the pawn Queens
characters captures and now you will
most likely draw this as you do have a
nice pass pawn g3 rook c8 you're gonna
go
to rook to c1 and mount the regards the
queening square but it's very unlikely
that you will be able to get more than a
draw because you constantly have to keep
an eye on the pawns here and even after
you get a pass spawn here the bishop
nicely covers here so it's it's not a
problem but yeah after this King 2 is to
remove Bishop captures wouldn't be
wouldn't be all that great for Anand so
here instead of capturing on and played
rook to f1 and it was in this position
that Alireza future resigned as he feels
like there's nothing more to be done
here and there in fact there isn't
because whatever you do you are never
crossing the light square so there's
that and well now you're going to lose
the pawn there's a double attack on the
pond there's no way to defend it there
there's nothing you can do here you
could try going for route d3 and trying
something like rook characters with
check row captures Bishop captures to go
into an opposite color Bishop endgame
but doesn't really work because well you
will lose this pawn as well and then
it's just four points against against
two deaths that's no way to try and hold
the draw but yeah so I have to look to
f1 otherwise I resigned and an excellent
to win for Volusia oniton Anand and the
beautifully played endgame so so far
Alireza was leading the tournament he
had some very very well some excellent
wins but when it comes to facing the the
absolute top elite of the chess world he
still struggles a bit not so much he
doesn't miss anything it's just that
he's still not there so so far the games
he lost is against Wesley so a current
world fish random champion Magnus
Carlsen who's the world champion for me
on corona the well form of Rogers
Championship Challenger and Vishwanathan
Anand former world champion so those are
those are the beasts that he still
cannot can attain obeah will see will be
very exciting to see how how strong this
tournament will make ali reza and where
he will take it from there so that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it we're
gonna cover at least one more game from
from eleventh round of the of the 2020
Tata Steel and then we're gonna check
out the standings
probably tomorrow I'd like to thank both
of branch
Florian Bonin giovanni russo salmon
johansson and stephen Valente for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check through my previous videos
here thank you for watching and I will
see you soon I continuing the coverage
of the Tata Steel of course checking up
on the Women's World Chess Championship
we have to we have to check out that
what happened in the tiebreaks checking
up on your wonderful suggestions and
when I catch a break a continuing the
morphe saga of course so thank you I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your Friday